When I started in game development,
state of the art graphics
were based on pallet's.
So, you have a certain number of slots
for the different colors you could
display at once, and
typical screen resolution was tiny.
Imagine how chunky a game would look
at 320 x 240, or even 320 x 200.
Just a few years later, there were
flip phones with higher resolution.
It was certainly a challenge
to make games look good.
Especially when you were limited to 32,
or 64, or even 256 colors.
If you wanted to shade an object,
for example,
you had to make sure to reserve space in
the palette for the color gradations.
Usually just a few inches each for the
major colors like red, yellow, and blue.
It's also made anti-aliasing
tricky because
it's basically just color blending.
So there goes more of your palette.
At the time we were using dot products
to do rudimentary light source shading.
Everything had a very cartoony
look since the colors didn't
change smoothly over
the surface of an object, and
they tended to pop between values
as objects moved in the scene.
We didn't care.
We just thought it was cool that
shapes were more realistic looking,
even if they were really crude.